I've been in business for 14 years. I
run a portfolio of companies that last
year did over $250 million in aggregate
revenue. Few months ago, I broke a world
record [music] for the fastest selling
non-fiction book and generated over $106
million in just under 3 days. Recently,
I sat down with a 100 business owners
where I shared tactical advice that I've
learned from the past decade of
business. So, everything from sales to
marketing to hiring to productivity and
even mindset. And so, I'm going to
compress a decade of business knowledge
that I've learned into lessons that you
can use right now. Starting with number
one, you're not disciplined if you like
the thing you're doing. So, I'll give
you an example. So, I used to work in
the fitness industry and I had lots of
fitness business owners who'd say like,
"I'm so disciplined." Because they were
like, "I work out at 5 a.m. every day. I
never skip my my meals or my workouts or
whatever." But the reality was I would
then ask that same business owner, "Hey,
how have you been doing with working
your leads?" Ah, you know, I haven't
been working them as hard as I should.
Blah blah blah blah. And so, I would
then look at them and say, "You're not
disciplined because you only are
consistent with the things you like."
Discipline is about being able to be
consistent with things you don't like.
So, here's me going into more depth
explaining that exact concept. Do you
consider yourself disciplined?
uh with things I like,
>> right? So, it's not discipline,
>> right? And so, I bring this up because I
obviously have talked to trainers and
gym owners for a long time. So, I I know
how to
>> Yeah.
>> I say this because um I [clears throat]
just have a lot of people in the
community that I ran be like, you know,
I'd see them posting every day like,
"God, I have discipline. Up at 5 a.m.,
like blah blah blah blah blah." And I'd
be like, "You never work your [__]
leads, bro.
>> Like, what are you talking about? You
like lifting. You like boxing. That is
not hard. It's like I I there it takes
no discipline for me to hang out with
Ila. Zero. Right. And so because some
people don't like hanging out with their
wives doesn't mean I have discipline
because I do like hanging out with my
wife. It just means that they have a
shittier life. Right? And so for you
it's like you have to this might be a
muscle that you haven't used. Like you
happen to like boxing and so you did
more of it and people said can you help
me? And you said sure. If you want to
get to where you want to go, your
frustration tolerance, meaning your
ability to do things that you don't want
to do without an immediate reward for an
extended period of time, is going to
have to get stronger.
>> And the good news is that that's a
skill. It's not a trait. You can learn
it. Which means you do 10 outreaches
tomorrow and you're like, "This sucked.
Nothing happened." And you say, "Great.
Tomorrow I will do 20."
>> And then you do 30 and then you do 50
and then you do 100 and you keep going.
But I promise you, if you do the rule of
100, which is in that book,
[clears throat]
>> you do a rule of 100, you and you do
that for a 100 straight days, your
business will grow.
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> I And what's crazy is that people
actually fully commit to it. And then
like way before day 100, they're like,
"Holy cow, my whole business has
changed." But like, you have to commit
to it. You have to go all in on it. And
I say it's 4 hours a day. This leads me
to business lesson number two. Most
already know what to do, but simply
don't do it. And the main question is
why? Well, number one, because of an
inability to delay gratification. Number
two, because they don't fully know how
to do something. This is the most common
reason in more successful business
owners. And a business owner asked me
this exact question. When all the
information is available, why are
entrepreneurs still stuck? And so, this
is what I told him. I'd say at the most
basic level, it's because of an
inability to delay gratification. And
so, if we just think about like why do
humans do things in general, it's
because they're they've been rewarded
more for doing what they're currently
doing rather than changing what they're
doing. And I think that makes sense from
an evolutionary perspective that like
more of what you're currently doing is
safe. And so people once they find
another point of equilibrium, it's very
difficult for them to break out of that
even if they're quote like mentally like
I really wish I could scale. They they
want to want to scale but what they
really want is to do what they're
currently doing which is why they're
doing it. Um and so I think um being
able to clearly articulate also like the
actions. So how is just like such a
simple word. It's a short word but has a
lot of like depth to it which is um if I
were to talk to a toddler and say I want
you to scale a business they would just
look at you like what
um if you were to tell me hey can you
scale this business I'd probably say
yeah I can and so the specificity of a
request is inversely correlated with the
skill of the recipient meaning if you
have somebody who has very low skills I
have to say like okay here's how you
turn on a Once you turn on a computer,
then you're going to open up Safari.
What's Safari? It's an internet browser.
What's the internet? Okay, let's explain
what the internet is, right? And then
eventually you're like, "Okay, we're
going to go to Google. What's a Google?
We'll get there. Don't worry. We go to
Google. Okay, finally we're going to
sign up here. You're going to get an
email. Once you have an email, I don't
know how to type. Great. Let me teach
you how to type." And so the thing is is
like the lower the skill level of the
individual, the more aggregate skills
they have to learn in order to chunk up.
>> And so sometimes people hear the word,
oh, you just need to do outreach. But
that is a bundled term that has a
hundred things underneath of it which is
like how do I warm up a domain? How do I
set you know what's an opener? how do I
integrate my you know clavia with my
whatever right like how do I integrate
these tools and so there's a hundred
how's underneath of it and they'll
usually get stuck on one of the hows and
being unwilling to try because it's so
frustrating of like
>> I think I think what makes
entrepreneurship feel slow is that you
can try to learn something for a day and
not have an outcome and then have to
come back to it tomorrow and figuring
things out is by nature a wandering
activity which means that if you knew
how to figure it out then you wouldn't
have to figure it out because you'd
already know it. And so it's people do
deal really poorly with uncertainty. And
so entrepreneurship, a lot of it is just
the the ability to tolerate uncertainty,
which feels very painful the entire time
you're in the uncertain period, which is
what I honestly think a lot of the pain
of entrepreneurship is wondering whether
the investment you're currently making
today, the thing you know you're going
to lose, the money, the time, the
effort, the sweat, is going to actually
pay off to the thing that uh you hope is
going to happen. And you don't know when
it's going to happen. And so it's almost
like if you run a marathon, you know, it
ends at 26 miles or 0.2, I don't know,
for you runners. Um, but like for
entrepreneurship, it's just someone
saying run.
>> Yeah.
>> And like, I'll tell you when to stop.
And even if you like just that idea
almost sounds torturous of like just
run. It's like well how long? It's like
run.
>> It's like but what if my lungs start
hurting? Run.
>> Keep running. And I think that's what
what makes a lot of entrepreneurship
painful. And then the idea of even me
saying this, some of you guys probably
had your heart rates go off, right? Even
the idea of not knowing when something
is going to end or in other words when
you're going to figure it out. A lot of
people just don't want to start that
race.
>> And so they know what they're currently
doing. And it's they get more rewarded
for talking about scaling, for talking
about their goals than they do for
pursuing them, which involves a lot of
uncertainty, f pain, and frustration.
So, this leads me to the next lesson
where I want to talk about one of the
most important mindset/skills that you
need to train yourself on if you want to
grow as a person and your business. And
at least that's what's helped for me and
that's actually self-awareness. So, I go
deep on it right now. The hardest thing
for people is judgment, which is like
how do I how do I know to listen to this
guy versus that guy, right? That's the
hard part because you will see
conflicting advice. And if you were to
ask two people who are both wealthy what
someone should do, if you were to ask
the Indian question, what should someone
focus on? English might not be the first
answer from Richard Branson. I don't
know, maybe it is. Um, it also doesn't
mean that his advice is wrong if it were
different than mine, right? Maybe his
advice is more right. No idea. Um, but I
think understanding what is right for
you given your existing resources and
skills is probably the most valuable
thing, which is self-awareness. And so I
think I've always had a decent amount of
self-awareness which has allowed me to
make sure that I'm picking the products,
services, information that I'm consuming
the most of around whatever I believe
the constraint to be. And then I would
say that I'm relatively maniacal in the
focus that I have around whatever the
thing that's limiting me is. And so when
I got into when I was like, "Okay, we're
going to start this family office." I
think I read 15 books in like two weeks
on, you know, different family office
structures, different investment thesis,
um, books by people who ran big hold
just so I could get some better idea of
this stuff. And I would say 15 books is
not like a huge amount of information,
but it was like just to give an idea of
like I did nothing else besides read.
Um, and so if I thought that sales was
the issue, I think people try to solve a
problem one way. I tend to approach a
problem with like I don't care which one
works. I will do all of them violently
and one of I will I will will my will
this thing through. And so if like I
needed to learn sales, I wouldn't be
like, "Oh, I'll read a sales book." It's
like, I'm going to read many sales
books. I'm going to consume all videos
on sales. I'll hire somebody who's good
at sales to teach me and review my stuff
in real time. And I will keep doing this
until sales is no longer my problem and
then I'll be like more which what's my
next issue and then I'll just bomb the
hell out of that thing. And I think
people take too little action around
what the constraint is. So either they
haven't properly identified the
constraint of their business or they
take insufficient action to solve it or
both. And I see commitment and focus as
as very similar like kind of sister
twins um
which is just the elimination of
alternatives.
And so I think most people are not that
committed.
And so I think I it's really it really
comes down to that. Like
it's one of the one of the things that's
really difficult to explain. And it like
there's a few lessons like from a human
nature perspective or from a skill-based
perspective that are very difficult to
see unless you're there. And consistency
is one of them. So is volume. And they
tend to be the two things that are most
required in order to get to where you
want to go. And so like you can't
witness consistency unless you are also
consistent in order to witness it.
So like you can't see me come to the gym
every day at 4:00 a.m. unless you were
there every day at 4:00 a.m.
And you can't see me work all day unless
you were also here working all day. And
I can say it and it takes 2 seconds. But
when you witness it and you see it every
single day, it has a different impact.
And I think that's what what a lot of
people miss out on. And like I talk
about volume a lot and I repeat it so
many times and I talk about focus so
much because like those are the things
that really separate the people who end
up winning and the amount of volume that
it takes is just so much more than
you're prepared for. And I think if
people really knew how much volume and
repetition it took they wouldn't begin.
And so I don't even think it's a bad
thing that people don't understand
because like if you really saw how far
away the goalpost was you'd be like I'm
not I can't do it because you can't do
it. You couldn't even comprehend that
because you're so far away from that
type of person or that level of
entrepreneur who'd be able to do it that
it seems unfathomable, but you think
it's a couple steps ahead of where you
are and then you get a little bit of
better and then you realize it's
actually this much further. But then you
get a little bit better and then you
realize it's this much further and then
eventually you start to realize like
when you look back at how much you did
in order to get there and then you're
like, "Oh, that's why." Now, let's
expand on the topic of distractions a
bit more because if you were to boil
down most of the business wisdom that's
out there, it's probably just two thing,
which is focus and patience. So, I want
to share some tactical advice on how I
personally stopped getting distracted by
all the shiny objects and new ideas that
I have because every entrepreneur has
enough new ideas to kill their business.
So, I want to provide some examples to
drive that home and give you my thoughts
on how I approach new ideas. I'll tell
you a story. I was talking to a friend
of mine. Um, he just inherited a billion
dollars. His father was in private
equity. he now manages their family
office. And so I was talking to him
about acquisition.com and school and
some of the other things and he was
like, "Yeah, man." He said, "Sometimes
the most profitable thing you can do is
wait."
>> And so I think that um that might be the
most profitable thing you can do. Like
doing nothing is something.
>> It's an action. I mean, [__] I mean,
how much willpower does it take to not
start new things?
>> A lot.
>> Right. And so I think you should give
yourself credit for like I you're
banking goodwill with the business.
>> Yeah. Um Jeff Basos had a a speech
recently that he did in Italy. Some of
you guys I shared a story of it for
those you follow my Instagram. Um but he
talked about his his rate of releasing
the work. And so basically he said if I
had 30 minutes I could write a 100 ideas
on the whiteboard that would destroy my
company.
>> And so you have you you absolutely have
enough ideas to kill your business.
>> So what we want to do is prevent that
from happening. And so um this is super
tactical but for everybody because this
is like really really really
dramatically changed my trajectory as an
entrepreneur. I have a lot of ideas,
which is like I kind of scratch my itch
of ideas because I get to idea about
other people's businesses and then I go
home and then Leila's like, "Do you want
dinner?" And I'm like, "Yeah." But I
forgot that we have a business, too. So,
I wasn't allowed. I didn't I didn't I
didn't have a way to mess that one up,
right? And so, and so and so what I do
is I I honestly have a document that's
called Alex's big list of ideas.
>> And every time I have an idea, I totally
flush it out. I I put, you know, I put a
link on the dock to another doc that has
a big memo that has like, "This is how
it work. this is what we'd make. This is
how blah blah blah blah blah blah. And
then I keep living my life. And then
when I finally see the team looks like
they have smiles on their faces, like
they're well-rested, they have a glint
in their eye. Then I pull back out my
big list of ideas. And what's
interesting is that like some of the
ideas that I'm like, "This is going to
be huge." I'm like, "That's why would I
think that's a good idea?" Um because
you get so emotionally charged and sold
on the idea while you're in the process
of the idea, in the throws of the idea.
But when you get a little bit of space,
you're like, "Oh my god, this is how
other people would hear this idea." And
I agree with them. I think it's a
terrible idea.
>> But every once in a while, um I'll give
you an analogy from uh um the Sandra
Bulock movie with the the offensive
lineman. Remember that one?
>> Blind side. So she said that I actually
think about this a lot with ideas. She
said if you like a shirt, she's like,
you know, don't buy it, but if you go
home and you're still thinking about it,
you know, a week or two later, like you
should probably go back and grab the
grab the shirt or whatever, right? And
so I think about that with ideas. Like
if I'm able to like I have this fear,
what if I forget the idea? If I forget
the idea, it wasn't that good of an
idea.
>> But the ones that like keep you up at
night, that keep gnawing at you, those
are the ones that like I'll flesh out
more and more and more, but I still have
to release the work at a rate that the
business can handle. And so then it
gives you respect for the output
capacity of the business. And then what
ends up happening, which you real like
you realize as you scale up, is that
manpower is almost always the limiter
>> is talent.
>> Which is why you see the the
billionaires on stage and they're like,
"Guys, you just got to get a good team,
you know, find good people and get out
of their way. But the issue is that good
people don't want to work for you, not
you. Entrepreneurs in general. And so
that's why like we have to go through
this kind of bootstrap phase sometimes
where we have to prove that we can earn
the right to get true A-level talent
because if you had the best AI person in
the entire world, you could have a
multi-billion dollar company within the
next six months. The problem is that guy
doesn't want to work for you.
>> And so it's like who do I who do I need
to become and what do I need to build in
order to get that level of talent to
come with me? And so we actually like a
lot of in my opinion a lot of the
entrepreneurial journey is creating the
proof
>> that then allows you to attract the
talent that's required to build the next
thing
>> like the level of talent we were able to
attract after we sold gym launch versus
while we were scaling gym launch night
and day not even close. And so I see
that as the trajectory and what also
ends up happening is that you end up
becoming like a collector of talent. Um,
and so the like and if you do write by
people throughout the entire process,
what happens is the stars stay around
and they come with you from thing to
thing. And so all of a sudden the bench
of stars just keeps getting bigger and
and they don't want to work with other
people cuz they're like, "We we have a
great team. We have a great culture. We
know how we do things here." And so in
the beginning of your career, you have
no stars. You're the only star. And then
and maybe you're a half star, [laughter]
right? Um but eventually you'll get one
other star and you're like, "Oh my god."
But the reality is like if everyone
thought like man if I only had 10 of
these people I could be 20 times bigger.
You will get there. It's just it takes
way more not stars that you thought were
stars that you then have to fire and
replace with another person that's also
not a star to get another person to then
replace with another person that's not a
star. And I fundamentally believe that
the reason that you can scale so much
faster the second time or third time
around. Who here has been uh who here
this is not their first business? Can
you get raise your hand real quick?
Okay, cool. Keep your hands raised. Um,
if you if this is not your first
business and this this business you
scaled faster than the businesses you
did before, keep your hand raised,
right? And like why why is that? It's
not like the physics of business
changed. It's just because your pattern
recognition improves. And in order to
get the pattern recognition, it's like
you have to just get punched in the face
a bunch of times with shitty people. And
so like for me, like I know of a
vertical stack of what a a salesdriven
org looks like up to a few hundred sales
guys. Like I know what that stack looks
like. I know what an SDR looks like. I
know what an SDR manager looks like. I
know what a closer looks like. I know
what a closer manager looks like. I know
what a a director of sales looks like. I
know what a VP of sales look like. And
they have different archetypes and they
have different skills and they have
different behaviors. But if you've never
done it, then you hire a VP of sales and
he sucks. And you hire another VP of
sales and he sucks. You hire another VP
of sales and she sucks. And then all of
a sudden one comes in and you're like,
>> you don't suck.
>> This is amazing. And then from that
point going forward, either that person
comes with you or you know exactly how
to pattern match and so you find the
person really fast and fundamentally
every level of the business. It's kind
of like bricks, right? You like keep
putting these level of bricks as you
scale. The problem is that only one of
those bricks prevents you and sometimes
for years because you are lacking this
hole and you don't know what it looks
like when it's right
>> and that's one of the big issues. And so
the goal is like how can I how can I be
willing to have a hard conversation
which means that I might like this
person as a person but they're not doing
their job. and how quickly can I can I
can I close that gap so that I can
replace them with somebody who's good.
The hard part is that we don't like
having hard conversations.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's like I mean I do like the
quote like the difference between where
you are and where you want to be is the
number of hard conversations you're
willing to endure.
>> Yeah.
>> And a lot of people just aren't. So to
ask answer the original question of like
why don't people do what they want to
do? A lot of them just can't have a hard
conversation.
>> Real quick check this out. So, if you
aren't sure what strategic competitive
advantage you should be doubling down
on, um, I'd love to invite you out to
one of our scaling workshops, uh, that
we have here in Vegas at our
headquarters and my team can actually
work with you on it. But before you do
that, you can download our free $100
million scaling roadmap, um, where you
can plug in your information and it will
give you basically your step where
you're at in the scaling process and
ultimately give you the things that you
can help get to the next level. But like
I said, if you want help from my team,
you can book a call after you download
this. It's free and we'd love to uh, see
if we can help you out. This leads me to
the next lesson. The person with the
longest time horizon wins.
Fundamentally, there's so much
competition. Some of the only alpha
that's left over, meaning arbitrage of
value, exists for people who are simply
willing to wait and endure longer. So,
let's expand on that. So, I think the
person with the longest time horizon
wins as long as that time rise isn't is
is reverse engineered to some level of
reality. So, I think Elon is the richest
man in the world right now because he
has wanted to build rockets, wanted to
build cars, and wanted to go to space
since he was like seven. And so he has
wanted to do this one thing his whole
life and he said it in his I don't know
if you guys seen this like his Zip 2
like when he was like hadn't even sold
his first company he was like I think
cars are really cool like electric cars
can you imagine and like rock like he's
talking about this then like this has
been what he's wanted to do his whole
life. Um I would say for me I would say
that my time horizon is not as long as
Elon's which is probably why I'm not as
rich as Elon. Um but for me it's like I
can probably see like call it three to
five from now. Um, and I plan for that.
And beyond that, I'm like, I don't know.
I might be in a different person,
different life, who knows? But that's
kind of as far away as I can see. It's
very difficult to have vision when you
have bills to pay.
>> And so, you have to get that situated
first in my opinion. You have to get
your like personal stuff figured out.
And then you'll buy yourself breathing
room to think further.
>> Yeah.
>> So, in that case then, am I thinking 3
to 5 years? No, I think you figure out
how to like go to a million dollars a
year and like don't worry about anything
else.
>> Say that again. I'm sorry.
>> I think you think, how do I go from 100K
to a million? That's my whole focus. And
you can do that in a year.
>> Yeah. Um
>> and like when you do that, because the
thing is is when you do that first level
of going to like, you know, 100 to a
million or 100 to 300, whatever the
number is, right? You will have more
resources and more skills. And so what
happens is your vision of the board will
change. You'll see the way the game's
played differently. And so I see the
people who are like the best at the game
as the people who see reality the most
clearly.
>> And so if you've been doing something
for a long time in your business and it
hasn't been getting you what you want,
it's usually because you don't see
reality as clearly as clearly as you
think you do. You see distortions. And
so I think as people go up up wealth,
it's because they actually are better at
predicting what's going to happen, which
is why they make more money than other
people. And so that's why I see
entrepreneurship as one of the best
sources of personal development because
you get slapped really quickly to find
out whether you were right or wrong. So
I want to quickly talk about AI. It's a
hot topic. Some people are very excited.
Some people are very scared. And some
people think it's going to replace
everyone and everything. And so I'm
going to share my views on AI as the
next portion of this TLDDR. AI is not
going to change the fundamentals that
make business business, but it will
change the tools available to the
players and sometimes in the future even
the players themselves. There's
opportunity more now than ever before
because the leverage of the opportunity
has increased. And so if we define
leverage as the difference between what
you put in and put what you put out, if
you can get more out for what you put
in, then you have higher leverage. And
so with AI, this is where they'll be the
first, you know, one person billion
dollar companies, 10 person billion
dollar companies, etc. And so people who
have um more a more AI enhanced
business, which the business that you're
in does have more of those levers, then
yeah, they will get more for what they
put in. Eventually, if they're like,
"Well, no one will do it because AI can
do everything." Well, if you take AI to
the natural extreme on an AI can do
anything that a human can do, then you
can say that about literally everything.
And so, I don't think it's super
productive. And so, I reverse it to what
what will this knowledge change about my
behavior? And so, my perspective or I
take the position that
since the dawn of time, it has been man
plus tools against man plus tools. And
right now we just have man plus better
tools. And so nothing has really
changed. Until the day it is man against
machine and the machine wins. And so
until we get to the day where we're
going headtohead against machines, it's
still the same game it's always been,
just more fierce. So I want to shift
gears here a bit and talk about one of
the most important components which is
sales and pricing. So there are a few
concepts that I want to cover. The first
concept is how I go about pricing a
product. The fundamental principle I
follow is either sell extremely
expensive to a select few or something
super cheap to everyone. The middle is
where people die. And so fundamentally
big picture, if you will sell something
that is not scalable, then you want to
sell with the absolute highest gross
margins to the people who can afford
that ticket, which makes sense to sell
to people who have lots of money to get
the money from them. On the other hand,
there's tons and boatloads of people who
have very little to no money. And so if
you're going to serve those people,
whatever char whatever price you charge,
if it's even moderate, it's going to be
a huge percentage of their income or
their savings, which makes them very
needy, very hard to serve. And so the
only way to serve that customer is
develop a product that is truly
scalable, truly unlimited scale. And
that is when you serve the people who
have small ticket things. Let me give
you more context on the thinking
process. I prefer I think it's a higher
you you maximize likelihood of you
making more money if you are a service
provider to go up market and sell to
people who have more money and then
eventually you can create a business
that can retain customers um that has
almost zero incremental cost of adding
additional customer
>> and then in that instance you absolutely
can sell to the masses Amazon sells to
the masses right there's not I'm not
saying Amazon is a bad business it's
exceptional business right um but they
also had to raise $680 billion dollars
of capital in order to build it. And so
what happens is entrepreneurs who are
under capitalized and unskilled think
okay I'll just serve the masses with
this thing but I don't have I don't have
the capital and I don't have the skill
in order to actually scale it. That's
the issue. And so for the vast majority
of quote unscalable businesses or less
scalable businesses that require humans.
That's where I prefer to say okay well
if you're going to do the same work you
might as well get paid 10 times as much.
Great. Because there is an audience of
people that would pay you 10 times more
because they just don't know you exist.
The reason the reason that it's so tough
to service the bottom end of the market
is that for them the small amount of
money is a huge percentage of their
income or their savings. And so they
will have the expectations of someone
who gives you their life savings.
>> And so there's almost nothing that can
satisfy,
>> right?
>> And so you will you will drain your
reputation and you will drain the morale
of your team because there will never be
something that is enough.
>> And also those tend to be the types of
people who want you to promise
everything in order to get your $10,
right? And I I I prefer not to live my
life that way. I prefer to say you will
get I would prefer to set my
expectations at zero and then you have
be pleasantly surprised rather than
promise the world and never be able to
fulfill. Now the next sales concept I
want to talk about is one of the most
common mistakes I see entrepreneurs
make. So fundamentally they don't have
an issue with how they're selling it or
what they're selling but actually it's
when they're selling it because the
right offer at the wrong time is still
the wrong offer. And so this is why
sales timing is so important. So let me
explain on this a bit more. You want to
make sure that we sell at the point of
greatest deprivation, not the point of
greatest value. And so, this is one of
the big mistakes that people make when
they're trying to sell stuff is they
actually sell at the wrong time. And so,
I'll give you an example. So, if we go
to a restaurant, you order a steak, you
have an amazing steak, and I say,
"Awesome. How was it?" You say, "It was
great." I say, "Awesome. Would you like
another steak?" And you're like, "No,
I'm good." And I'm like, "Why wasn't the
steak good?" And you're like, "Yeah, it
was great." I'm like, "Then why don't
you want another steak?" And you're
like, "Cuz I'm I'm good. It was I'm" I'm
like, "So, you didn't like the steak?"
And you're like, "No, I loved the
[__] steak, dude. Like, back off."
Right. Right. And so, and that's because
like the offer is right, the timing is
wrong.
>> And so, if I wanted to sell two steaks,
what I would do is say, "Hey, sir, how's
it going?" You say, "Great." I'm like,
"How hungry are you?" And you're like,
"Dude, I'm [__] starving." And I'm
like, "Guy like you, you're going to
need two steaks." That's when you sell
two steaks.
>> Yeah.
>> Before you've had your first bite,
before you're full. When you're at point
of greatest deprivation. Where people
get confused is they're like, "Hey,
people got a lot of value. That's when I
want to sell." The point of greatest
deprivation and the point of greatest
value only sometimes intersect when once
you've created the value, you create
deprivation around the next thing.
>> And so the motivation for any person to
take action on anything is the amount of
lack they have. Deprivation. You're
incredibly motivated to sleep when
you're exhausted. You're incredibly
motivated to eat when you're starving,
incredibly motivated to [__] when you're
haven't. Right? And so the idea is we
want to extend that's why in a pitch
it's all about the pain. It's like how
can we agitate the pain? How can we
extend where they are to where they want
to be and make this gap bigger and
bigger and bigger? For us in a monetary
world, which is what you sell in, the
gap isn't physiological.
It's um it's perceived. And so, we have
to build up the perception of
deprivation. And if any of this is like
sounds like too complex, just stop me.
But basically, when you get around
people way richer than you, you feel
poor.
>> And then when you feel poor, you get
motivated to get richer. If you're the
richest person in all the people that
you know, you have no motivation because
you're the you're the richest man in uh
not Babylon, but the poor part of
Babylon, the hood of Babylon, right?
[laughter]
Do you do you know what I mean there?
>> Yeah.
>> The next sales concept I want to talk
about is how do you sell without giving
away all your secrets? Right? A lot of
people are afraid when they make
content, well, what if I give away all
the secrets? Like no one will have
anything to buy from me, which is the
exact opposite because 99% of people are
never going to buy from you, but they
will judge you based on the quality of
your free content. And so the idea is
like give away all the information and
then sell the implementation. So many of
you guys sell um information education
media related stuff. Um where people
make mistakes where they're like how
much do I teach versus how much do I
pitch, right? The issue is not
understanding what kind of information
you should teach at each stage. And so
there's two types of education. There's
declarative knowledge and there's
procedural knowledge. This I didn't
invent this. It's just education system
last 100 years but people just don't
talk about it. So um uh declarative
knowledge is knowledge about something.
This is what you use to sell. Procedural
knowledge is about how to do something.
This is what you sell. If you use this
to try and sell stuff, people will walk
away with a shitload of to-dos and
they're like, I'm good.
>> Mhm.
>> What you want to talk about is all the
things about how it works, about the
outcomes, about what is possible. teach
how how it works conceptually, not so if
I say I'll give you an example. Hey, you
have a business, you're doing $2 million
a year. If you go from two million to
five million, you cross over the
institutional threshold. At that point,
your multiple goes from three to seven.
And so, you go from having something
that might be worth $4 million to
something might be worth $35 million
just by adding another $3 million in
revenue. And here's why that is. Because
institutional buyers, blah blah blah
blah blah. Me explaining that, people
are like, "Whoa, that is really
interesting. I didn't know how all that
worked. I didn't teach how to do it. I
teached about how it works.
>> That still is incredibly valuable
because the what's really nice about
declarative knowledge is that everyone
gets value from it because you just have
to be there to get the value.
>> When you teach tactics, you have to do
the tactics to get the value, which
means they can't do it with you. They
have to go and then do it and then they
would extract the value, right? So, it's
at a delay, which means they don't want
to buy right now. And so, whatever
you're teaching, you want to be
predominantly declarative in nature. Let
me teach you about this stuff that you
aren't aware of. This is where breaking
beliefs around specific uh I think like
this is the old model. This is the new
model. I'm not teaching you here's how
you set up a domain. Here's how you warm
it up. Enzo, right? Here's how you have
an AI agent. Here's how you personalize
the f like we're not teaching that.
We're saying did you know that if you go
from not personalized to personalized
this is the increase? Whoa. I'm not
gonna I'm gonna show you that's how it
works and then I will sell you how to do
it. Mhm.
>> That's what you separate. Again, secrets
implementation. The next sales concept
is about training your sales team. So,
this happens a lot where you've got
maybe three, four, five guys, let's say,
and you've got one guy who's a star and
he sells half the volume or she sells
half the volume and the rest of the team
sells the other half. Often times, that
one star suppresses the rest of the
team, number one. Number two, doesn't
follow the scriptor process. And so,
scaling that team becomes very difficult
because there's no consistency across
reps. And so one of the things that a
lot of business owners want to do is
like, man, if I only had six Sarah or
six Shauns, I'd be good to go. But there
is a way to get six Shawns or six Sarah,
and it's by breaking down what they do
into significantly more detail than you
probably have, and then training far
more frequently with far faster
reinforcement cycles to actually get
that to be duplicated. Now, that might
have sounded like a lot of big words.
So, let's dive into what that means. And
the big thing with sales training that I
think the vast majority of businesses
underestimate is just how much training
is required to make a truly world-class
team. I think 90 So everybody who has
the sales handbook can kind of get you
guys have my schedule for how we onboard
and how we train. And I think for many
people that's a big belief breaker. It's
hard for people to comprehend exactly
how much we train at acquisition.com.
It's a shitload. Um and so to give
context on that, our sales team trains
every single day. Every day. And they
all role play every single day. And
every week they have a one-on-one with
Game Tape, with their manager of what
they specifically need to work on and
like that muscle. And like do you know
how to train like do you know how to
train a salesperson?
>> Um I would say no.
>> Okay. So you train sales people through
like role playinging until your eyes
bleed because fundamentally it's the
fastest feedback loop that you can give
someone in terms of training anything.
So they say something and so the way
that we train is number one is you have
to memorize a script. And so the way you
memorize a script is you put the script
in front of someone, they print out a
second script, and then they read the
script out loud, and then they black out
one of the words, and they read it
again, and they black out another word,
and they read it again. And by the time
you blacked out every single word,
you've said the script for as many times
as there are words in the script, and
you tend to [__] know it. And so then
you're staring at an entirely blacked
out page saying the entire script.
That's how you memorize a script. Once
you can breathe the script, which is
what we call it, once you can breathe
the script, then we practice the role
playing component, um, which is us going
back and forth. And so when you're
reading the script with someone, we have
a hand up with heads nodding. And the
first time someone's going to go through
a script, we're going to say, "Hey, just
to be clear, we're going to interrupt
you probably like 50 or 60 times by the
time you get to the end of it." That's
okay. The worst way that do people do
role playing is that someone they go
through a whole roleplay or someone just
says the script. That's the worst way.
The second worst way is that you go
through it and we quote roleplay and at
the end the guy says all right so you
know at the beginning you could have
done this a little bit different and you
know you kind of said this a little bit
bad at the end you probably should have
offered it like this. No one's going to
remember that. It doesn't matter. It's
way too late. The reason that
superstition happens is because you
change something and then you
immediately get feedback. And so once
someone does it, we call it locking it
in. So it's like they mess something up,
we say, "Hey, stop. Try it like this. Do
it again." They do it. If they get it
right, we say, "Great. Lock it in." That
means do it again. Do it again. Do it
again. Keep going. And so that's how we
trill the script so that every person
delivers the script the same way. The
vast majority of sales teams have a
script. It's loose. No one really pays
attention to it. And the way that they
recruit sales people is that they just
hire a bunch, see who sticks, and then
let the rest go. Exceptional sales ors,
which I consider us to be, can take
anyone to be a savage.
It's just a question of how much effort
we're willing to put into somebody. As
long as you know how to train the skill
of sales which ski sales is so trainable
as a skill um that's the feedback loop
that has to get created. So the first
step for you is we have to observe the
salesman and then we have to document
the words they say and what they do.
Once we have that that becomes the basis
for the memorization and then the role
playing becomes making sure they execute
that and I always want adherence above
everything. So we are like the New
England Patriots in terms of how we run
the sales team which is the process is
above everyone. No one's better than the
process. And the way we position that is
like thousands of sales calls, thousands
of hours have gone into like men died
and gave their lives to give us this
script. You were not better than the
script. And so you say the script
because we know these words close people
period. And that's the approach that we
have and that's the difference that we
give to the process. And so if you have
a star salesperson, one of the difficult
parts is that that person tends to be a
cowboy, right? Does whatever he wants as
long as he clos deals. That is a
cultural issue. it will be a cancer long
term if he's a primadonna and so most of
the time I would rather have a team of
all eights closing on a 10 out of 10
process and that team will always
outperform a team that has one star and
no process. Okay. Now in this next
section I want to talk about influence
and branding and the reason this is so
important is that fundamentally branding
is building a history of positive
reinforcement with a large audience that
ideally has a high likelihood of
purchasing from you in the future. And
so think about branding as
pre-programming sets of behaviors. And
so if I have a a cold audience and then
you have a branded audience or people
who have an association between you and
the thing that is good, right? Then
these people are going to be far more
likely to take a desired action, right?
And so branding is the action that we do
as businesses to make those associations
to increase the likelihood they comply
with our requests. Aka, they do what we
ask them to do when we ask them to do
it, which is like, "Hey, go check this
thing out." or hey, go buy my thing or
hey, go schedule a call or hey, check
out my next video or hey, read this
email. Whatever it is, you have to build
a history of reinforcement that shows
that the last time they did something
good, something good happened for them,
which makes it more likely that it
happens in the future. So, I'm going to
break down a four-part framework in
thinking about this so that you can gain
influence, not just reach and views for
you and your business as an
entrepreneur. So, there are there are
four components of influence, right? You
have SPCL, special is the easy way to
remember it. You have status which is
the number of reinforcers that you
control. The stuff that people want you
control that. The second is power which
is say do correspondence which is when I
tell someone to do something if they
follow those instructions a good thing
occurs. You gain more influence. The
third is credibility. So is there a
third party world that proof that what
[snorts] I'm saying is true. And then
fourth is likeness. How similar are they
to me? Now, in this audience, it's
mostly men around my age. Not all,
obviously, but I have a
prepoundonderance of dudes around my
age. [laughter] Um, and so that's
because likeness is a strong influence
on that. Ila talks about many of the
same things that I do, and her audience
is 54% female.
>> Is it like, and if I were to talk about
her stuff, I'd probably still have more
men, right?
>> Um, and so, okay, you're like, "All
right, I understand that." And so, how
do we reverse? And I'm going to talk
about each of these in a little bit more
detail, and then we'll talk about how to
apply to video. Okay.
>> So, from the the the status perspective,
each of these operate independently, but
can also be combined. When you have all
four, it's significantly more
influential. And so, a kid who has a
trust fund and a kid who doesn't have a
trust fund, somebody who's rich
inherently, didn't earn it, but just is
rich has more influence than somebody
who doesn't. Now, do they have the most
influence? No. But if that person was a
trust fund kid had or sorry rather
somebody who had a lot of money and gave
you 10 stock tips and out of the 10
stock tips all 10 worked and you made
money on all of them on the 11th stock
tip the likelihood that you would follow
their request is high
>> if they had credibility it's okay do I
have proof that these things occurred
outside right now some of these boxes
can check multiple things and so if he
gave you stock tips and they worked and
then he gave you and then he gave you
another stock tip he has credibility he
has power and he has status. If he said,
"Here's another investment that's not
stockreated. Here's a real estate
investment." He no longer has
credibility, but he does have power
still because other things you generally
have listened to have worked, not
specific to the thing that he's talking
about. And then finally, if he looks
like you and he talks like you and he's
your twin brother, much more likely that
they're going to listen. And so in any
of these situations, if it's just a dude
who looks like just like me, I'm more
likely to listen to him than an old
lady. I'm just more likely to. If
somebody has credibility around the
thing, oh, I scaled a sales team. I'll
give you a different example. If I
scaled a company to a billion dollars
and I had zero equity in it, but I was
the CEO, I would have credibility. If I
was also the founder and had all the
money, I would also have status. Now, if
I've never given you any advice in the
past, I have no power over you. If I
then gave you advice and it worked, then
I have three of the four. And if you
look like me, I have all four. Right?
And so, the idea is that if we want to
gain influence, we want to have as many
of those loops demonstrated as often as
possible in the content that we have.
The reason I start every video with my
name is Alex Herozi. I have an
acquisition.com portfolio last year over
$250 million a year. And the reason I
make these videos is so I can help you
do XYZ so we can eventually blah blah
blah. All right. I do that because I'm
trying to demonstrate these things as
fast as I can. I try to demonstrate
status, credibility. The power occurs
from how good the advice that I give is.
And that is if I had to pick one of the
four to have, it's that one. It's how
well can you give people directions in
order to get something good to happen.
So, uh, some of you guys have heard of
Martha Stewart, hopefully. Um, Martha
Stewart's a goat. I have a tremendous
amount of respect for her. She was the
original influencer, one of the first
ever. And everyone was amazed that she
became the first self-made female
billionaire. No one talks about this.
First self-made female billionaire. Why?
She literally gave women instructions
for years on how to do stuff. And then
they followed those instructions and
then good things happened.
>> They made the cake. Exactly. And then
everyone said, "Ah, you're amazing,
mom." And they do that over and over
again. So when she says, "Buy my book,"
they're like, "Of course I'll buy your
book. every other thing that you've told
me to do has worked for me. Now, one of
the best ways to have strong influences
by building a strong brand, which I
covered earlier. And so, fundamentally,
let's go more tactically into how to
build one. So,
so what is brand, right? Brand is the
association we make between two things
through an outcome, right? That's what
brand is. So, thing you don't know,
thing you do know, you put thing you
don't know next to thing you do know. If
you have positive associations, these
positive associations transfer until
eventually you don't need to have this
thing anymore. Positive associations
maintain. That's what branding is
fundamentally. It's teaching its scale.
So like if I brand the the so this is a
tree, right? And if I say tree to a kid
over and over again, they will associate
the sound with that thing. And so then
eventually they will say, "Oh, that is a
tree." And so branding will have
occurred, right? It's teaching. And so
what happens is you have your existing
brand, right? And then you have the new
association that you want.
And we have some people that may get
left behind and say, "I don't like this
new association." And then you will have
some people that you will gain as a
result of the new association. This
would be an even trade. The ideal
branding move would be like this.
We lose this, we gain this. And so
whenever you change a brand from
anything, you will always lose some and
net others because any change will get
some people to say no and other people
to say yes. And the goal of good
branding is that we net more than we
lose.
And so for me, if we think about the
elements of brand, we have reach. So how
many people, you know, see it? We have
influence, which is uh the percentage
likely they comply with their request.
Will they do what we ask them to do? And
there was direction, which is like you
can have influence and then it's against
you, right? Like Trump has super high
influence and polar [laughter]
just both sides, right? Like people are
like, "But he changes people's
behavior."
>> So if they see it, they're either I hate
him or I love him. But either way, their
behavior changes, which means he has
influence, right? And if a lot of people
have that, then it's even bigger brand.
Your parents have super high influence,
very small reach. So all of our parents
here, or most of your parents, if you
didn't have parents, sorry. Um, but let
me tell you how parents work. Uh, so for
most people, parents have super strong
brand for you for very tiny reach. So in
other words, you'll have a strong brand
when you have large reach, high
influence, and in the right direction.
So let me explain what happens when you
build a strong enough brand, right? And
so but like but that's but that's
exactly the point. This is like once the
brand gets high enough, then you can
just make the offer with no promises and
say, "Hey, every other thing that you've
bought from me has been good. You'll
like this, too. Trust me." And then
people will buy. And as long as I keep
that promise, the next time I have a
thing, hopefully you'll still want to
get it. Um, and then that cycle
continues to reinforce. And so that is
the brand loop. It's like what other
what what you say about you, what other
people say about you, and then finally
what the customer thinks about you after
delivering the product. At that point is
the final the final point. So like said
differently, if you're going to go see a
movie, you see the advertisements of the
movie first. And then you're like, "Huh,
that looks interesting." And then a
friend of yours sees the movie and
they're like you're like, "Was it good
or bad?" And they're like, "Oh, it was
good." You're like, "Oh, okay. Now I'm
way more likely to see it." But then
when you go to the movie, you don't
really care what your friend said.
You're going to make your own call on
whether you like the movie or not. And
so that is the reinforcement loop that
occurs with brand. It's just that most
people Where's my Where's my homie?
Where's my Where's my Indian guy? Where
you at? Yes. So the reason that the you
keep doing more offers is because you
say it's great. You get a handful of
testimonials because if you sell a
thousand people, you can get 10 people
to get a good result because they're
going to get a good result no matter
what because there 10 out of a thousand
are going to have something good happen.
So you get your 10 results and then you
convince people and then they buy and
then all of a sudden those people say,
"This sucks." And so then you have to
start all over again saying this new
thing is amazing and great and then get
your 10 testimonials from your beta
group because you can take a 100 people
and 10 of them are going to get a
result. You talk about the 10 results
that are good. This is obviously lying
in advertising by the way. Um and then
you go to sell the product and it sucks
and then you just do that loop forever
and that is what most internet marketers
are doomed to making the right hires and
be able to train them is one of the
highest leverage things that you can do
as a business owner. Now one of the most
common push backs I'll get is well they
can't do what I can do. So, if you want
someone to do something and they're not
doing it, I want to share a framework
that might help. And I call this the
management diamond. Now,
I'll give you the little management
diamond um that I do for employees,
which is a really good framework for
having hard conversations.
But if you want someone to do something
and they're not doing it, you have like
four or five reasons that they're not
doing it, right? The first is they just
didn't know that you wanted them to do
it. Most common. Hey, did you do that
thing? thing and they're like, "What
thing?" You're like, "Damn it, I didn't
write it down, did I?" Okay, so we have
to write it down. We have to We have to
put a deadline on it. Fantastic. So now
I say, "Why didn't you do that thing?"
They say, "Well, I didn't know how to do
it." Okay.
Well, fine. So, they didn't know how to
do it. Now, let's say we train them. So,
I told you that you needed to do it. You
know how to do it, but um you didn't
know when I was going to do it by Oh, I
need to do that tomorrow. Okay. So, I
knew that you needed to do it. You knew
how to do it. you knew when to do it.
The next is you have something that's
blocking you. So, I knew that. I knew
how. I knew you wanted to do it
tomorrow, but you also told me to do
three other things.
Which one did you want me to do?
And then finally, you get into this,
which is that
I didn't want to do it. Which in my
experience is the first place that we go
to as entrepreneurs and typically the
last one that's reality. Most people, I
have found when they have a job, prefer
to keep it. And I've also found that
most people prefer to feel like they're
doing a good job at their job. And so,
it's usually one of these other issues.
And so, this provides a really good
framework for having those
conversations. Now, the reason I bring
this up is because we can also have
these conversations with ourselves. I
know I need to do more. Why am I not
doing more? Did I not know that I needed
to do more? Well, now I do. Okay. Do I
not know how to do more? Oh, I don't
know how to do more. Great. Well, now I
have something to attack. That becomes
my to-do. If I don't know how to do it,
I know what to do, which is to figure
out how to do it, right? Um, is it not
urgent enough, right? Or is there
something blocking me? I would go
recruit more people for my HVAC company,
but right now 80% of my time is dealt
with these customer service issues that
are coming up onesie twies all day.
Okay, great. How much does it cost to
replace the onesie twoosie thing? Cost
me $60,000 a year. I have 400,000 in
profit. Am I willing to go from 400,000
to 340,000 in profit in order to get 80%
of my time back? Yes. But that means I'm
gonna make less money. Yes. Today, but
then I'm gonna get 80% of my time back
so that I can then focus on how to
figure out how to do more. And so it's
just it's taking second and third order
consequences down to their natural end
and then ultimately being like, okay,
this is what I need to do. I literally
went through this process. So post
launch for me, I was like, okay, I have
this bandwidth back. What's the next
trend of the business? And for me it was
six questions down for me to be like
that's what the issue is and that's what
I'm focused on. And so right now 80% of
my time is dealing with that constraint
which is I'm heavily recruiting
executives right now. That's what I'm
doing with my time. Yesterday I had four
executive meetings and I have follow-up
notes and and connections afterwards
that I have to do. That's what my time
is right now because that's the
constraint of the business. And then
once that finishes because those people
get onboarded and they do a good job,
I'll go through this again. Now, one of
the most common limiting beliefs
entrepreneurs have is that no one can do
it as good as they can. But this
eventually creates something called
keyman risk. And this is the next
business principle that I use. And so,
fundamentally, every business, if it's
relying on any person, whether it's the
entrepreneur or otherwise, it's that
person is going to be keyman. Now, this
is a double-edged sword because the
better you get at something, the more
keyman you are. And so, the more you've
invested in yourself, in some ways, you
become a liability for the business as
much as you are an asset. But this
applies across the board. And so the
only real way to pay this down, I'll
explain in this little clip.
>> So one of the big issues that especially
like when you're coming up, the problem
is that everyone here we like we had to
learn all these different things, right?
We had to learn marketing, we had to
learn sales, we learned product, we
learned hiring, we had to learn all this
different stuff, right? And then we we
want to hire one person who's lived our
entire lives and then expect them to
work for us for a fraction of what we
pay ourselves and are barely even
willing to keep doing what we're doing.
>> Right.
>> One of those.
>> Yeah. So we have to break it into parts.
And so I give the analogy of the
unicorn, right? So like you're a unicorn
in your business, you [snorts] looking
for unicorns is probably not a
productive activity. But if you wanted
to create something that was an
approximation of a unicorn, it's like,
okay, well, I need the horn. So I can go
find a rhinoceros and I'll I'll get the
horn part. And then uh but that body is
not going to work. So I got to go get a
horse. It's going to be a white horse.
It's not going to have a horn. Well,
fine. I can get the horse. But then what
about the magic pixie dust, right? So
then I got to get my fireflies and I can
add those on. And so I just bolt on the
horn of the rhinoceros onto the horse
and get some fireflies. Is it as good as
you? No. But it'll be pretty good. And
so if the business requires somebody
who's as good as you to run, then the
model doesn't work. If the business can
work with somebody who's half as good as
you, then you're always going to
sacrifice some margin in order to scale.
And so I'll say this differently. One of
the terms I use is scale zero. And so
the goal is like how can I get so let's
say that let's say hypothetical math if
I do something I make $20 million a year
and it's 50% margins and I'm heavily
involved in a whole bunch of [__] right
if I hire truly all the people that I
need maybe my margin goes from 10
million to four let's just be extreme
here but I do nothing now but now that
company can then go from 20 to 40 and I
can make eight on 40 and it requires
zero of me. And so again, it's this a
lot of times we have our ego tied to
because you said it, you're like, I got
to this and as soon you're like and then
as soon as I'm there, there's this ego
like and so it's because you have this
tie for whatever reason that like if
it's not this number, you suck or
whatever that is for you. And so we need
to be able to give up some of that
profit in order to break your your the
activities that you currently do into
component parts. The activity of doing
that is we do time studies. So you look
at what you do in a current week and
then you start parsing out. Okay, you
could take the entire time study, plug
it into GPT and just say, hey, what
roles uh if I were to replace 100% of
these activities, what if this is the
smallest amount of roles that could
replace all of them and give me the job
description and names for those? And
it's like, okay, well actually you do
things you do some HR [__] and you do
some uh marketing stuff and then you do
some sales [__] Okay, great. So you
need one of these, one of these and one
of these. And it's like, cool. how much
is going to eat in my margin? I'm going
to cut half my margin away. Okay. Am I
willing to do that so I can actually
have something that works? And the first
time you hire them, two out of the three
will suck because you don't have pattern
recognition. And then one of them will
be okay. And then you'll hire again and
it'll take you six months to figure that
out. And like, but that thing is is that
once you get there though, you will
finally be able to get to 500 or million
a month or whatever the next stopping
point is. And then you'll be like,
"Fuck, I don't know how to hire this
next person." And then you'll fail for a
while and then you'll get it.
>> You just can't stop. You can't stop
trying.
>> Just look at what you do. Mhm.
>> Like what do you spend your time
actually doing? What you think about all
that stuff doesn't really matter. All
that matters is like I communicate these
people in these ways. I make these
decisions.
>> So fundamentally you're most of the time
you're going to be making decisions or
you're going to be doing some sort of
individual contributor activity. Those
are going to be the core elements of
what you do, right? If you want ideating
then maybe that's going to come here and
then we'll make a decision about it,
right? But most small businesses don't
need more ideas. They need more
execution. And so we just have to break
what you do day-to-day to the buckets,
the constituent parts of what they are
and just take all the mysticism out of
it of like visionary and the energy and
whatever. It's just like you do this
stuff. This stuff makes money. We need
other people to do that stuff. So I want
to move on and talk about culture. So a
lot of entrepreneurs throw this word
around and they don't even know what it
means and so that they want to improve
something they can't define which makes
it very hard to improve. And so I will
walk you through how I define culture in
this clip and more importantly how to
improve it.
>> So and I I bring that up because many
times we as entrepreneurs will say I
really want to fix this thing and then
we say cool then what's that?
>> It's like very hard to fix if we don't
know what it is.
>> Sure.
>> So I define culture as the rules spoken
and unspoken that govern reinforcement
in an organization.
>> So what are the rules? If that like and
then what is a rule? A rule is a
conditional statement of if this then
that.
>> So if you do this then you will get
rewarded. If you do this then nothing
will happen. and if you do this then
you'll get punished. So culture is a
series of rules that govern what happens
good stuff bad stuff when you do things.
>> And so the reason that culture I think
is so difficult for people to transpose
from one to the next is that there's so
many rules that govern behavior within
an organization that people are like you
just got to be around there and like
soak in the culture which really just
means you need to observe many rules and
conditions of reinforcement occurring uh
over an extended period of time to
understand how the rules work here.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And so as a result, people just
don't codify the 100 plus rules of
behavior. Um, and so there's kind of
like I would say two paths that you can
do. I would say my preference and then
what's probably the easier faster one.
So my preference is actually codified
all and say like what are all the things
that make us us? And of course you're
going to have your values and whatnot,
but I see values as chunked up rules. So
if I were to say I have 200 rules of
behavior that I want to say these are
the things that are rewarded, these are
the things that are punished. Okay, how
can I chunk these into three statements
or three bulleted words that when
unpacked would mean that if I believe
this to be true, this is the set of
behaviors that will go along with it.
That's that is how I would approach um
this type of thing. If you want to do
the fast fast and dirty way, you have
the three values and then you just try
to describe them the best way you can
and that's how value should be created.
Um, but I do prefer the like let's do
more of that work and say like how are
all like how do we like and think about
when you're thinking about these rules
think about the conditions where
behavior exists and it'll be much easier
for you to think about the rules of
behavior. So it's like within a meeting,
what are all the rules of a meeting,
right? So maybe at acquisition.com, if
you're not talking, you're muted. That's
a rule. And if you talk while you're in
a meeting and you're not talking like
you're not talking to everyone else,
like that's like close to grounds for
termination.
>> Um just because it means you're not
paying attention while you're here, then
like you know, what are we doing?
>> Uh so it's like one of things. So it's
like what are all the conditions in
which we interact? What are the rules of
engagement around those interactions?
And then that codifies up to three, you
know, three statements that should chunk
up what culture means to you. And then
when you have that as the limus text
when you go and transpose that to the
new location, one, you want to make sure
that the leader does actually adhere to
those sets of rules and ex um behaviors.
And my my way of doing this would be to
take the the biggest culture champion
here and move them there, provided that
culture can still reinforce itself
without that leader. Death creates
clarity. A business owner asked me about
what I meant by death creates clarity.
And I want to leave you with this
message.
>> Death creates clarity.
>> Yeah.
>> What are you clear on today?
>> I think it creates a forcing function
around prioritization. And I think that
like um
I mean it's the ultimate razor of like
will this matter? And I think that
writing I think writing my mother's
eulogy was really valuable for me
because if anyone here has written a
eulogy or an obituary or anything like
that, you get to see what's included and
what's not included. And a hilarious
amount of the things that we stress
about in life are not included. Also, a
hilarious amount of the things that we
strive to achieve are also not included.
And so when I think about and I think
Charlie Munger is the first like he's
the first person that I know said I'm
sure plenty of people have said it
beforehand but um I love the concept of
the reverse obituary or the reverse
eulogy of like what would Alex's eulogy
be? It's only going to be 500 words to a
thousand. That's how long eulogies are.
Which by the way you're like wow that's
not that long. Um cuz people are there.
They're busy. It's you know it's r it's
rush hour. they got places to be and
you're not trying to take too much time
and so you have to write it out. And so
usually like the accomplishments we have
like if I really think about like what
the you know the Alex funeral is going
to be
no one's going to give a [__] about how
much money I made or anything like that.
No one like imagine Titan of Industry,
right? Like some people want to be cover
of Forbes or whatever it is. It's like
when you go to that guy's funeral,
you know, they don't start with like he
was a titan of industry. Okay, fine.
That was one sentence and that was that
covers 40 years. Great. Uh but then
they're going to transition to two
things which is what I saw as the common
theme which is service and character.
And so in thinking about like what what
are the things or what are the causes
that I that I deem meaningful enough to
serve and then what traits uh do I need
to exhibit in order to become the person
capable of serving them at the highest
level. I think everything that we do
between now and then or at least for me
is in service of that eulogy or that
obituary. And I think that's the I think
that's the reason that you know death
creates clarity at least for me. When
you have those nice moments it's like
what can I how can I benefit from this?